monsieur le président de l'ukraine
monsieur le président du sénat mesdames
et messieurs les députés sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs les représentants
du corps diplomatique
c'est un honneur pour nous de vous
accueillir au sein de l'assemblée
nationale nous connaissons votre
attachement à la france où vous avez
effectué votre premier déplacement
officiel à l'étranger
après votre élection comme président
d'ukraine vous aviez ainsi engagé dès
2019 un dialogue fructueux avec la
france je tiens également à saluer la
présence parmi nous de l'ambassadeur
d'ukraine en france monsieur vadim
omeltchenko
[Applaudissements]
oui
depuis maintenant près d'un mois de
guerre les ukrainiens se bat et résiste
de façon héroïque à l'agression
militaire russe soyez sûr monsieur le
président de la solidarité et de
l'entière mobilisation de la
représentation nationale nous
continuerons de veiller à ce que tout
soit mis en oeuvre pour vous porter
assistance qu'il s'agisse de l'adoption
de mesures restrictives à l'encontre de
l'agresseur ou de la fourniture d'un
soutien humanitaire aux ukrainiens comme
réfugiés nous avons tous vu ces images
choquantes bouleversante de villes
ukrainiennes bombardée et assiégée
la france condamne ces actes et ses
bombardements indiscriminés
visant les populations civiles
cela doit s'arrêter immédiatement et
nous appelons la russie à se conformer
au droit international humanitaire dans
ces circonstances tragiques
le peuple ukrainien fait preuve d'une
résistance admirable je tiens à saluer
son courage et celui des autorités
ukrainiennes sachez que nous demeurons à
vos côtés monsieur le président de
l'ukraine vous avez la parole
merci
merci c'est un grand honneur pour moi
pour le cren et pour notre peuple
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
les élus de paris le peuple français
je suis reconnaissant d'avoir l'honneur
de m'adresser à vous aujourd'hui
je suis sûr que vous savez très bien ce
qui se passe en ukraine vous savez
pourquoi cela s'est produit et vous
savez qui est coupable
et même ce qui est ce qui cache la tête
dans le sable
et c'est de trouver de l'argent en
russie
et je m'adresse à vous aux gens honnêtes
rationnelle et audacieux
et je voudrais poser une question
comment arrêter cette guerre comment
instaurer la paix en ukraine parce que
la plupart des questions et des réponses
sont dans vos mains dans nos mains le 9
mars
les bombes aériennes russes ont été
lancés sur l'hôpital pour les enfants et
une maternité dans notre vie de mario
paul c'était une vie
paisible dans le sud de l'ukraine
complètement paisible jusqu'à ce que les
troupes russes sont venus et l'ont pris
dans un siège brutal comme au moyen âge
ils ont commencé à tuer les les gens
dans cette maternité
sur laquelle le russe ont lancé les
bombes il y avait des gens il y avait
des femmes qui se préparait à accoucher
et la plupart d'entre eux
ont survécu mais certaines ont été
gravement blessées et une femme a dû
amputer son pied qui était fracturée
une autre femme avait en bassin fracturé
et son bébé et moi revend la naissance
la femme on essayait de sauver la femme
elles demandaient les médecins de
laisser mourir de ne pas l'aider
elle n'avait pas de réelle ne voyez pas
de raisons pour vivre
et le mortes en ukraine en europe en
quand des centaines de millions de
personnes ne peuvent pas penser que que
le monde pouvait être détruits
et je vous demande d'observer une minute
de silence à l'honneur à la mémoire de
milliers de livres aignan et d'ukraine
yen qui ont été tuées à la suite de
l'invasion russe du territoire ukrainien
merci
après les semaines ils ont bossé en
russe marie paule et d'autres villes
ukrainiennes frappé par l'occupant
rappelle les ruines de verdun
comme sur les photos de la première
guerre mondiale
que chacun et chacune à vue a vu l'armée
russe ne distingue pas les objets qu'il
cible ils détruisent tous les quartiers
résidentiels les hôpitaux les écoles les
universités de dos ils brûlent les
entrepôts de nourriture et de
médicaments
ils brûlent tout
il ne prend pas en compte les concepts
de crimes de guerre
les causes obligations sur les
conventions et ils ont apporté la
terreur sur le seul kenya et j'attends
de vous un inconscient vous avez toutes
les informations d'autres disponibles
tous les faits sur les femmes violées
par les militaires russes dans les zones
temporairement occupés sur les réfugiés
qui qu'elle tue sur les routes sur les
journalistes qu'il tube sachant
exactement que ce sont des journalistes
sur les anciens qui ont survécu à
l'holocauste et sont maintenant obligés
de fuir dans les abris anti bombes des
frappes russe
l'europe
n'a pas vu depuis 80
ans dans l'europe n'a pas vu ce qui
s'est passé en ukraine
il y a des gens désespérés qu'il supplie
de mourir
en 2010 neuf ans je suis devenu
président il y avait déjà en format pour
les négociations avec la fédération de
la russie c'était un format normandie le
format des négociations qui devraient
mettre fin à la guerre dans le donbass
la guerre à l'est de l'île anne qui dure
depuis huit ans malheureusement
et quatre états ont participé au format
normandie l'ukraine la russie
l'allemagne et la france
4 mais il représentait tout le monde le
monde entier les positions du monde
entier toutes les positions quelqu'un le
soutenions et quelqu'un a essayé de
retarder le processus ils voulaient le
perturber mais il semblait important que
le monde soit toujours à cette table
normandie
et dont il y avait des résultats des
négociations quand nous avons réussi à
libérer les gens de la captivité et
quand nous avons pu négocier certaines
décisions en 2019 c'était une bouffée
d'air frais comme une leur d'espoir
l'espoir que les conversations avec la
russie peuvent aider que les dirigeants
de la russie peuvent être persuadé par
parole de moscou que choisir la paix
mais le 24 février evegnon le jour qui a
barré tous les efforts
et même le concept du mot dialogue
et la barre et l'expérience européenne
des relations avec la russie elle est
destinée de l'histoire en europe tout
cela a été bombardée par les troupes
russes écrasé par l'artillerie russe et
brûlé après les tirs de missiles russes
on n'a pas trouvé de vérité dans les
bureaux
et on est obligé de chercher la vérité
sur le champ de bataille
alors qu'est ce qui nous reste nos
valeurs l'unité et la détermination de
défendre notre liberté
notre liberté commune pour paris et pour
kiev pour berlin et varsovie pour madrid
et rome pour russell et bratislav
les bouffées d'air frais ne nous
aideront pas
nous devons agir ensemble
vers la pression ensemble pour faire la
russie a cherché la paix m mesdames et
messieurs le peuple français le 24
février
le peuple rien si tu y es aujourd'hui
nous n'avons plus ni de représenter en
3d représentant de gauche nous ne
faisons pas attention à ce qui est ce
qui représentait le pouvoir
et la coalition et l'opposition et on
pense de l'instauration de la paix
pour protéger notre pays nous sommes
reconnaissants à la france
que la france nous aide nous sommes très
reconnaissants pour les efforts du
président macron qui a fait preuve d'un
véritable leadership ne communiquons
constamment avec lui nous coordonnons
nos pas et les ukrainiens on voit que la
france apprécie également la vérité et
vous les protégez
vous vous savez ce que c'est la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité
et chaque parole est important pour vous
je le sens et les ukrainiens le récente
et nous attendons de la france de votre
leadership
que vous puissiez faire en sorte que la
russie cherche la paix pour mettre fin à
cette guerre contre la liberté contre l
égalité contre la fraternité contre tout
skieur rendu l'europe unie et
libre et
diverses nous attendons de la france de
votre leadership la restauration de
l'intégrité territoriale de l'ukraine on
peut le faire ensemble
et s'il ya ceux qui ont des doutes entre
les personnes présentes alors je peux
vous dire que votre peuple est sûr comme
tous les autres peuples de l'europe
et pendant la présidence française de
l'union européenne
une décision
mûrie sur apprises sur l'adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'union européenne une
décision historique à un moment
historique
comme cela a toujours été le cas dans
l'histoire du peuple français
mesdames et messieurs le peuple français
demain ce sera au mois que les
ukrainiens se battent pour leur vie et
de leur liberté
que notre armée se pose de manière
isolée et or et ori rooryck aux forces
supérieures de la russie
nous avons besoin d'eux dad encore plus
date de plus de soutien pour que la
liberté ne perdent pas elle doit être
bien armé les chars les armes antichars
les avions de combat la défense est rien
vous pouvez nous aider nous en avons
besoin vous pouvez pour que la liberté
ne perdent pas le monde doit le soutenir
avec des sanctions contre l'agresseur
chaque semaine on ne voit pas cas de
sanction les entreprises françaises
doivent quitter le marché russe renom
auchan leroy merlin et autres doivent
cesser d'être les sponsors de la machine
de guerre de la russie
les
îles doivent arrêter de financer le
meurtre d'enfants et de femmes le viol
tout le monde va se rappeler que les
valeurs
valent plus que des bénéfices
et nous devons déjà pensé de l'avenir de
la façon dont nous allons vivre après la
guerre il faut des garanties de garantie
sûre que la sécurité sera inébranlable
et que les gars ne seront plus possibles
dans ce monde
nous créons ce système de garantie en
nouveaux systèmes de sécurité
où la france aura un rôle de premier
plan pour que personne
ne devrait jamais en pleurer la mort
pour que les gens vivent leur lit
et pour qu'on dise à dio pas sous les
bombes pas en état de guerre
mais quand leur vient
avec la dignité parce que nous devons
vivre pour être respectées
pour conter guise d'au revoir
comme les français a dit au revoir à
belmondo
merci apprend ses couloirs à l'ukraine
nous remercie de vous être adressée aux
parlementaires et au peuple français la
séance devait